Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy here with more of the truth about
the notorious Council on American
Islamic relations that is care Belling
its claims to reject and repudiate
terrorism care has a long record of
opposing counterterror initiatives since
its founding care has been consistent in
opposing virtually every counterterror
measure ever implemented or proposed
even the most innocuous it strenuously
objected to a 2007 Los Angeles Police
Department Plan simply to map Muslim
communities the program was ultimately
discarded care was also in the Forefront
of opposition to a New York Police
Department program conducting lawful
surveillance of Muslim communities that
program too was ultimately abandoned for
years K's spearheaded opposition to the
Patriot Act and in 2011
care was one of the 57 Muslim and South
Asian organizations that wrote to Barack
Obama's counterterrorism Zar and current
CIA Chief John Brennan demanding that
counterterror training materials be
purged of all mention of Islam and Jihad
effectively leaving FBI agents and other
officials ignorant about the motives and
goals of jihad
terrorists on the other hand there is no
evidence of care ever vocally supporting
any counterterror initiative or
encouraging other Muslims to do so a
further clue to Care's true nature is
the fact that numerous care employees
have been arrested or deported on
terrorism or other National Security
related offenses gasan elashi was the
founder of car's Dallas office he was
convicted and sentenced to 65 years in
prison for 10 counts of conspiracy to
provide and the provision of material
support to a designated foreign
terrorist organization 11 accounts of
conspiracy to provide and the provision
of funds goods and services to a
specially designated terrorists and 10
counts of conspiracy to commit and the
commission of money laundering along
with one count of conspiracy to impede
and impair the IRS and one additional
count of filing a false tax return
Randall or Ismail Royer was a care
communication specialist he was
sentenced to 20 years in prison for
firearms and explosive charges and for
assisting in recruiting Fighters for
lascar a taiba the terrorist group that
carried out the Mumbai massacre in India
basam cfagi was K's Community Affairs
director kagi was sentenced to 10 months
in prison and deported for his role in a
material support for terrorism scheme
involving an Islamic charity Nabil sadun
was a care Vice chairman who was
deported from the United States for
failing to disclose an association with
the Hamas link United Association for
studies and research which was founded
by the openly identified Hamas leader
Musa Abu marzuk muthana alanui executive
director of care Michigan was sentenced
to a year in prison for violating
sanctions against the Iraqi government
for having received oil contracts as
payment for services to Iraqi
intelligence abdurahman Alam mudi was
car Northern Virginia's executive
director and an extremely influential
moderate Muslim in Washington for many
years he turned out to be also an
Al-Qaeda finer and was convicted and
sentenced to 23 years in prison Robie
Hadad a former care fundraiser was
deported for a Visa violation the
immigration judge ruled that Hadad was a
threat to National Security in part due
to his role as chairman of the global
relief Foundation which was a charity
linked to financing Al-Qaeda care played
a role in directing funds to the global
relief Foundation after 911 what's more
care officials have made statements in
support of convicted killers and Jihad
terrorists while routinely denouncing
foes of jihad Terror care officials have
a long track record of public statements
in support of terrorist organizations
convicted terrorists and other convicted
violent criminals terrorists and
convicted Killers publicly defended by
care include Alam moodi who Not only was
an Al-Qaeda finer but was also involved
in an assassination plot against the
Saudi crown Prince care officials have
also defended Samy alarion who after
years of proclaiming his innocence
admitted to being a Palestinian Islamic
Jihad organizer likewise defended by
care officials was Jam Abdullah Amin who
was convicted of murdering one Georgia
sheriff's deputy and wounding another
other jihadis defended by care include
the blind shik Omar abdal Rahman who was
the ring leader of the 1993 World Trade
Center bombing Hassan nasrah the
Secretary General of his balah and Musa
Abu marzuk who as we have seen was the
deputy chairman of Hamas it will come as
no surprise that after all this that
care has received foreign funds in
possible violation of the foreign agent
registration act from organizations
linked to terrorism despite billing
itself as an organization working on
behalf of American Muslims in reality
care has received millions of dollars in
funding from foreign governments and
foreign organizations including the
world Assembly of Muslim Youth and the
world Muslim League both of which have a
history of support for terrorism and are
linked to the Saudi government from its
founding in 1994 up until March 17th
2010 car is believed to have received at
least
2,792 23 in contributions income and
money from foreign principles in the
form of 11 distinct transactions and to
have received a 2,100
6,251 mortgage loan from a foreign
principal for its Washington DC
headquarters and to have secured another
$54,500 th000 in pledges from foreign
entities most people believe that care
is a single tax deductible
501c3 nonprofit organization but in fact
this is not the case care is actually a
series of interlocking nonprofit and
for-profit corporations several of which
have under a series of confusing name
changes on the nonprofit Side Care
identifies or has identified itself as
the Council on American Islamic
relations as well as the Council on
American Islamic relations Action
Network the Council on American Islamic
relations foundation and the nondescript
Washington Trust Foundation or WTF
additionally care has maintained
substantial real estate holdings it
controls under the names Zahara
Investment corporation and the greater
Washington LLC of Delaware which is a
limited liability Corporation wholly
owned by care K's Byzantine
organizational structure is apparently
so confusing that even its own executive
director nihad Awad claims that he does
not understand how the system works care
has also repeatedly failed to properly
maintain the legal standing of its
various organizations and has failed to
file tax forms which has resulted in
having its corporate statuses revoked
government and media leaders who still
have contact with care should decisively
repudiate this unsavory organization I'm
Robert Spencer for Jihad watch